Десь високо-високо в горах…
І зять каже: давайте ми тут зробимо під туристів...
Або за сто кілометрів від Києва…
Відпочинок залежить від природи, від натхнення людини,
з яким позитивом вона приїхала.
Подалі від шуму міста…
Мені тут більше подобається, ніж в Києві.
Та ближче до тварин…
Відпочинок в автентичних сільських хатах, на фермах
чи просто на дачах подалі від міста.
Такі відпустки надзвичайно модні в Європі.
В Україні ж вони лише набирають популярність.
В гамаку серед зелені та з улюбленою книжкою за сто кілометрів від Києва.
Дарина вже не перший рік літню відпустку проводить
не серед шумних європейських міст, а у сільській хаті.
Тиша. Думала, що буде...
скучно. Але ні. Абсолютно ні.
- Чим займаєтеся?
- Читаю.
Якщо чесно, навіть у карантин не було часу читати.
А тут - читаю. І ось провели інтернет.
Тут в принципі до цього його навіть і не було, і теж було чим зайнятися.
Вмовити на такий "all inclusive" вдалось не одразу маму Дарини - Валентину.
Вона звикла до відпочинку в Туреччині та Єгипті.
Хочеться подивитись нове і думаєш, що там щось бог зна що.
А потім приходиш до того, що колись було.
І на цьому можна заспокоїтись.
Так, дійсно відпочивати у своїй країні добре.
В Україні надзвичайно великий потенціал для зеленого туризму.
Це добре знає Любов Гавловська.
Красива природа, історичні місця...
Її туристична фірма пропонує
як готельний відпочинок за кордоном,
так і в Україні
На вебпорталі фірми можна знайти понад тисячу різних приватних садиб
з різних куточків України з прямими контактами власників.
Та навіть у період карантину, каже Любов, попит на садиби невеликий.
Все ж таки надають перевагу зарубіжним турам,
вони вважають, що там краща якість.
Там харчування краще і більше.
І це не порівняти з тим, що наші пропонують.
В Європі зелений туризм став популярним ще у 50-х роках
рахунок, зокрема, державної інформаційної підтримки.
В Україні ж про сільський туризм вголос заговорили із підписанням
Угоди про асоціацію між Україною та ЄС.
Та чіткої державної політики у цій сфері ще досі немає,
зазначають у Спілці сільського зеленого туризму.
Надія Несторова свою садибу "Калиновий кущ", що в Богуславському районі на Київщині,
відкрила ще на початку двотисячних.
Тоді з сільської бізнесвумен лише сміялися.
Чоловік одного разу прийшов з роботи і каже:
досить мене позорити. Який туризм? Хто сюди буде їхати?
Це тобі не Західна Україна і не Швейцарія, щоб сюди хтось їхав.
А я кажу: нічого, Коля, поїдуть, ось побачиш.
Нині ж на одній вулиці Надія тримає дві хати в автентичному стилі.
Тут і піч з розписами і старі ліжка, яким за сто років.
За таку справжність туристи і полюбили садибу.
Радіють відпочинку на природі й діти.
Мені тут краще...
Для малечі господиня влаштовує особливі розваги:
то ліплять з глини, то вчаться петриківського розпису.
Для цього запрошує майстриню Тетяну.
Колись та й сама дивувалась, чого б це містянам
їхати в село та ще й гроші за це платити…
Поки не побуваєш у Києві, не поживеш там,
буває випадок від випадку, коли потрапиш туди, а потім вертаєшся.
Ось правда, тоді стає ясно, чому люди їдуть в село.
Коли в Києві посидиш, понюхаєш оте все.
Там шум, гам і голова квадратна, тоді зрозумієш.
Куди легше притягнути туристів у садиби, які знаходяться біля історичних місць.
Або у розкручених туристичних регіонах. Як от Карпати.
Цьому дерев’яному будинку, що у Верховині, понад сто років.
Колись стояв пусткою, тепер навіть у карантин має жильців.
Ми на Букінгу є і так люди нас знаходять.
А вже є такі, що бували у нас по пару раз,
були по 3-4 рази,
кажуть, що ми до вас приїдемо, своїх друзів присилають сюди.
В інтер'єрі тут відтворили гуцульські мотиви: оригінальні ліжники,
старовинні фотографії, що розповідають про обряди гуцулів.
Є тут і мінімузей.
Вона важить кілограми два-два з половиною. І називалась вона "желізко".
Діяльність садиб, які приймають туристів, нині регламентується
одним законом про особисті селянські господарства.
Він лише надає право селянам приймати гостей.
Втім цього недостатньо впевнені в Асоціації зеленого туризму.
Вони виступають за оновлення закону.
Серед змін, наприклад, те, що санепідемслужба чи інші контролюючі органи
не мають перевіряти стан садиби.
А все має тримається на взаємній довірі між селянами та гостями.
Так, для когось вбиральня має бути в хаті, а комусь і на вулиці підійде.
Саме в цьому і є родзинка сільського туризму, чи то гостинності.
Крім того, в законі слід прописати, що під сільським туризмом розуміють
садиби, де одночасно можуть розміститись не більше 10 гостей.
Такі норми діють і в Європі.
В Асоціації сподіваються, що нині в умовах карантину
влада зверне увагу на цей закон.
Адже сільський туризм є найбезпечнішим видом відпочинку:
туристи зазвичай приїжджають лише сім’ями чи невеликими компаніями.
І особливо не контактують з людьми.
Це підтверджує киянка Валентина, яка із-за подвір’я садиби майже не виходить.
На ганку розмірковує про те, чому ж у Європі так люблять сільський туризм.
Там швидше люди дійшли до цього:
що якось воно й рідніше
і харчування звичніше.
І краще, краще, мабуть...
А у нас ще.. Ви знаєте,
ми ж молоді ще - країна молода.
І нам треба пройти всі етапи,
щоб повернутись до витоків.
Про відмову від мандрівок за кордон не йдеться,
а радше про розширення видів відпочинку.
Тож, можливо, в недалекому майбутньому для українців села
справді будуть асоціюватись не з садінням чи копанням картоплі,
відпочинком для тіла та душі.